As you saw by that Beck test,
regression-based forecasting
can be useful.
It's also worth noting that that
particular Beck test was not
spectacular.
It did indeed beat the S&P 500,
which is important, but
it didn't beat it spectacularly.
[LAUGH] Usually we find that
performance in the real world
Is not as awesome as in back testing.
So we would probably still see
good return from that strategy but
it wouldn't be quite the same
as we saw in that back test.
So I want a list a few problems
we see sometimes with regression
based forecasting.
First of all, our forecasts always
seem to be noisy and uncertain.
So there is value in there, but
it has to be accumulated over
many trading opportunities.
It's hard to know how confident
you should be in a forecast.
I mentioned in my software demo
a moment ago that we could look at
standard deviation of
the nearest neighbors.
That works okay.
It's really not too strong of a measure,
however.
So it's difficult to know how confident
you ought to be in any particular
forecast.
It would be nice if you could know
because that would enable you to
essentially bet less on
forecasts that are less certain.
Additionally, it's not clear how long
you should hold a position that might
have arisen from a forecast, and how
you should allocate to that position.
These are all challenges using
regression based forecasting.
Some of these issues can be addressed
using reinforcement learning.
Where instead of making a forecast of
a future price, we had the system learn
a policy and the policy tells the system
whether to buy or sell a stock.
We'll get to this towards
the end of this class but
it's an interesting alternative to
the regression based approaches
we're going to use here at
the beginning of the class.